dix mètres carrés par client c'est
désormais la nouvelle jauge que tous les
commerces de plus de 400 mètres carrés
doivent observer une normes plus
strictes et qui réduit encore le nombre
de personnes autorisées dans un même
lieu
alors dans les enseignes comment
s'organise ton pour ne pas dépasser ce
seuil
éléments de réponse du côté de blois
dans un magasin de la grande
distribution
florent clavel dans cet hypermarché
chaque client compte un slogan usées non
la réalité du travail de cet employé à
la sécurité
la dupuch mais le comptage des personnes
qui rentrent et qui sortent du magasin
depuis ce week-end la jauge a été
réduite d'un client pour huit mètres
carrés un client pourront 10 mètres
carrés ici il ne doit pas y avoir plus
de 850 personnes en même temps
sinon on ferme le temps que les gens
ressortent et après choc est rentré ce
qui n'est plus arrivé depuis le premier
confinement
car ces dix derniers mois les habitudes
de consommation ont évolué avec une
meilleure répartition des flux dans la
journée le couvre-feu à 18h encore
accéléré ce phénomène on est obligé de
changer nous aura pour avoir moins de
monde moins de contact avec les gens du
coup moi je suis quelqu'un d'un valide
automatiquement je viens j'ai bien le
matin plutôt des clients qui s'adapte
résultats dans cet hypermarché les
restrictions de jauger d'horaire ont peu
de conséquences sur l'emploi
la quasi-totalité des 220 salariés
continuent de travailler tous les gens
sont en activité on a simplement réduit
les horaires le soir en ferment à 18h on
ouvre un peu plus tôt à 8 heures le
matin on a évidemment l' agence de
voyages qui est ouvert sur des horaires
restreints puisqu'il ya une activité
quasiment nulle sur le voyage et donc on
attend on a l'espoir que ça puisse
repartir un jour
en parallèle les ventes au drive ont
explosé + 50 à + 80% et ici pas de
problème de jauge